you know i we both have had a couple
paranormal experiences
oh yes wherever i go i'm i'm fascinated
by the experiences people
may have had no what did you what what
did you experience
okay i'm so as a child i'm
i swear you know growing up i'd always
want to do bloody mary
and all my friends are really scared
you're not talking about the cocktail
no no no for those who don't know what
bloody mary is you you stand vodka the
yeah yeah so at least the way i knew it
was you turn off the lights and you
chant bloody mary
three times right and she should appear
in the mirror you know me being a young
boy
um i i i was afraid to talk to girls but
i was like
thinking okay i could maybe handle
talking to a woman that's just in the
mirror
sure and so i was trying to get my
friends like hey we should chant bloody
mary because like
what if she's like really attractive she
might be hot whatever
mary's heart yeah like a baddie yeah so
i'm i'm telling you what if she's lit
yeah exactly i'm telling my friends like
if bloody mary's a baddie you're
sleeping on easily the easiest
opportunity to talk to
a girl like ever they wouldn't do it so
i had to do it alone bloody married solo
yeah a solo bloody mary so i do it
and she was there in the mirror for for
a split second it wasn't long
but she was was she hot she was so bad
dude
really yeah like unbelievably sexy she
was fine
think of the most attractive woman you
could think of and like that's how she
was built
her jaw was missing that was like kind
of scary but but in a hot way
yeah yeah it was because you know like
her eyes were just like beautiful
right like burning yellow i was like i'm
pretty sure i follow her on instagram
yeah yeah yeah there's no way yeah
bloody mary she's not
only fans sorry that's what it is no
that's a totally different bloody mary
oh okay but yeah i have an only fan's
page
do you what do you do on there
naughty naughty things for a monthly fee
wow yes i will send you a picture of me
in my me undies
at only 8.99 a month wow
me undies is a sponsor of my show as
well i'm well aware of all of them
i plan on visiting all of the meundies
sponsored podcasts
throughout the galaxy and do you wear
them when you
visi i'm in mine right now of course i
am okay yeah yeah
i wear three at a time how do you beat
so much micro model
fabric yeah yeah with the ultralight
breathe technology so breathable
so breathy i want to ask you something
plus i have that policy that if you're
not satisfied you get to return it
no questions asked no questions asked
yeah you can even get 15
off if you use our promo code when you
buy me undies as well is it dark or dark
air or what is it
um it's dark hair ours i believe is uh
tmg tmg tmg what does tmg stand for
a tiny meat gang oh i do not qualify
mean we we didn't think so to be a
paranormal expert you cannot be
small-needed yeah you have ghost dick
energy
thank you that's a compliment yeah yeah
oh thank you yes yeah
um swamp ape dick energy
cradles and caresses the well
my enormity right right some would even
call it an abnormality
it's it is paranormal penis
um another good band name yeah you were
gonna ask a question
yes i i want to know i was exposed i
guess
oh no i'm so sorry to hear that did you
tell the authorities to a paranormal
situation hmm yes okay so apparently
there's this girl on tick tock right
that claims to be
a psychic she's an an esp i don't know
if it's n esp or she is esp
she has yes esp extra sensory perception
right so she claims that she can read
thoughts
um and so she said that she was at an
mgk concert you know mgk machine gun
kelly
sure okay he's dating
he's a famous gangster though he died in
chicago in 1957
in a hail of bullets that is correct but
this is a new one he's an artist
i guess he maybe got the name right
mm-hmm
it's a potter he he's
in his spare time but professionally
he's a musician okay yeah okay does he
play the cello or the oh he plays
guitar yeah plays guitar sometimes yeah
anyway so he's dating megan fox are you
aware of her she's
certainly yes transformers yes exactly
great film
mm-hmm classic classic classic yeah
uh so she they're cars
and at the same time yes they're robots
yeah right come on i mean
win win it's like duh uh i love cars
i love robots put them together how did
you sign me up
yeah how did none of us think about that
we should do
a movie franchise with just combining
two things that we love
like yeah ice cream and uh what do i
love ice cream and
cocaine no um no trampolines
ice cream and trampolines yes anyway
so machine gun kelly megan fox which who
will cast in our movie
yes okay perfect would be wonderful to
see her jump on a trampoline
sorry that was so offensive i know i'm
sorry i'm sorry i don't know why i said
wow
it's so just grossly objectifying i'm
sorry
to a woman that has struggled so much
she's a mother of three
yeah that's true she's just gone through
a painful divorce that was all over the
tabloids
you're going to reduce her to just mere
body parts on a trampoline
i'm sorry man i'm sorry it was a it was
a cheap joke
she's an enormous talent she's been in
so many incredible films i agree
and now she's supporting this machine
gun man exactly
she also has esp that's what this girl
on tik tok was saying
i believe that megan fox also has esp
because
i was in the audience at this show and i
told her this is what the girl on tik
tok was saying i told megan fox
with my mind if you can see me right now
if you can hear me give me a sign
and she got home and megan fox not only
waved to her three times
but put her the girl in the audience on
her instagram story
and said i see you wow
yeah tell me what you think of that is
that proof well we have known
for decades that hollywood is infested
with certainly satanic forces but
also um a mysterious
collaborations between the highest
echelons of hollywood and
politics with ancient franchises
such as the rosicrucians and the
illuminati
i think that the illuminati have a great
capacity
for extra sensory perception and i would
wager
that perhaps megan fox
was part of m came ultra dosed
by the government in lsd psychic
experiments
uh in the 70s and um
is part of this uh this crossover
between
mk ultra the illuminati the rosicrucians
and uh and the devil worshipers
of uh the hollywood studio system jesus
holy [ __ ] the girl who fixed bumblebee
worships the devil
that's nice i love that bumblebee terry
what
what are you what are you thinking about
these days what's troubling you what
makes you excited
well um i'm not sure if you're aware of
this
but in the early episodes of dark air my
wife
uh zelon who passed away
three years ago she called in
to my late night am radio talk show dark
air and my life for the past several
weeks
has been one of a
part detective part
uh obsessive compulsive
part bumblebee i don't know but i
i'm trying to see if she's still alive
is it possible to call out to her you
know if we did some sort of like chant
here could we maybe try to call in her
presence
i think we should get try and get in
touch with megan fox
yeah and see if she could contact her
yeah megan fox if you're listening
come to my apartment at 13 37 and a half
kawanga boulevard i would love your help
with extra sensory perception and trying
to reach the spirit of my wife zeylon is
she still alive is she being held
against her will somewhere i don't know
we need your help please megan
and what do you have a trampoline
because it'd be nice to i'm sorry oh you
said
i'm so sorry i don't know why i keep
doing that i think the
megan fox visiting my apartment is
probably unrealistic why don't we just
try to channel her energy here candace
can we bring the lights low just a
little bit
there's a lot of different forces at
play up here in space that we've
realized
yeah so i think maybe we can utilize
that to maybe channel
yeah maybe just call out to her and see
if we can
you know capture some energy all right
stay alone say long if you can hear me
show us the sign should we chant with
you call out to her
[Music]
god oh my god oh my gosh
i was freaked we should stun it yeah
we need to wipe his memory
he can't remember this okay okay wipe it
wipe it
wipe it yeah
[Music]
i think that's good candice let's send
him back down
damn i think we went a little bit too
far yeah maybe
it was a bad idea just pulling somebody
up here no warning i don't think people
are ready to see it yeah yeah i think
they're ready for this
yeah yeah the whole anal probing thing
um hey guys uh is terry still here uh he
he literally just left you just missed
him yeah i'm sorry man
sorry man i'm a huge fan